we have here in the subconscious the
paradigm and part of the paradigm with
respect
to money
is
it's a poverty thing
now this paradigm
impacts our thinking there's a power
flowing into our consciousness
and the thoughts we think
are generally
motivated by the subconscious mind
now something that i've been
pointing out here recently
on
look at this
the subconscious mind is universal
intelligence
so when you have that paradigm in the
subconscious mind
that controls the vibration that we're
in
and the vibration we're in is going to
dictate what we attract because we're in
that vibration here on a conscious level
on a subconscious level and on a
physical so you're going to attract from
anywhere you go in the universe the same
type of thing that's that's what we're
attracting
so we're attracting people that are in
harmony with this and this paradigm
causes our thinking to be along the same
level
now
we've got to realize even in our
ignorance when we don't know and we
haven't got anything
our thinking is hooked into universal
intelligence
and you will attract from wherever it is
in the universe whatever is required
to cause the problem when you hear
people say
you know i just get one filled bill paid
and another one pops up
bang they're going to attract it
and sure as it gets dark they get it
now that's ingrained in our mind from
the time we're children
in fact
from the moment of conception in most of
us and then we grow into it and that's
what we hear is we're growing up money
doesn't grow on trees and and over and
over you can't have everything you want
you know
and
that is uh
that's got to be eliminated
and we've got to realize that is not
fact
that you do not have to work harder
that you do less
and you earn more
and you've got to get the idea that you
can have money coming in from many
different places in the world dragging
it right into you
you attract it
and you can magnetize yourself
to money
in all different quantities
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how you can
leverage the law of attraction
enjoy
rule number two develop productive
thoughts with bruce lipton money is the
equivalent of energy so you can buy
energy with your cash and the
significance about that is just if
you're frugal and take care of your
money and keep a balance then you always
have this energy in your bank account
energy in which you can live
however obviously if you waste this
energy then you actually interfere with
your own survival so you don't really
want to go out and just throw away your
money
and so basically i really want to show
you that this is an important insight
into the nature of our own health and
our biology in the world we create in
this regard that our biological system
the cells rely on energy without energy
there's no life so fundamentally you
have an energy budget that gives you
life and in fact in the body energies in
coins called atp molecules that
represent units of energy so in fact
biologists refer to atp as the coin of
the realm the significance of atp is
this
is that atp molecules are like units of
gasoline like gallon of gas that are
used to fuel our biological processes so
to stay alive we have to have all this
atp so there's an atp account in your
body right now but the question is how
do you use this atp and now here's an
important fact that
25
of the total energy in your whole body
is used to operate your brain so all of
a sudden you start to recognize that the
brain uses energy at the rate of muscles
of a marathon runner so a brain and
muscle activity are pretty much the same
and so why is this important because as
you're using your brain as you're using
your thinking you are actually using
energy now why is this relevant the
answer is very simply this because the
way we've been using our thoughts are
not necessarily productive a matter of
fact sometimes our investments of our
thoughts are actually counterproductive
because our thoughts create a reality
that we then have to overcome so
basically it says that we must start to
become aware of our thoughts and why is
this important because thoughts
represent units of energy every time you
have a thought you use energy
why this becomes relevant is if i give
you a checkbook for your bank account
you don't go down the street and just
write checks to people like oh hey
you're a nice looking guy here's 10
bucks for you and oh here little girl go
out and buy yourself a little car here's
a thousand dollars for you and you don't
give away your money why because giving
away your money is giving away your life
so basically you become very frugal when
you have a checkbook in your hand
now what i'm trying to tell you is this
you have an energy budget in your body
the energy is what keeps you alive when
you start using energy and writing
checks where you get no return from your
energy then it's exactly the same as
writing checks out of your bank
checkbook and giving away your cash so
why this becomes important is the
biology of belief
reveals how our thoughts create our
reality and if you start investing in
thoughts that are counterproductive
thoughts like fear what am i going to do
and how am i going to escape this
problem or how is this going to go wrong
and all these other kinds of thoughts
that are negative kinds of thoughts then
realize this
you are actually not just using your
energy for having these thoughts but
these thoughts are also what come into
your reality what you focus on with your
thoughts your brain will manifest as
reality everything you do in your life
you put out energy for
therefore start to review what you're
doing in your life because if you're
putting your energy into things you
cannot change in this world that is
exactly the same as writing a check and
just throwing away your money to the
outside because you get nothing back
from it so think about this very
interesting reality that you have this
energy checkbook and every time you use
energy you have to say is the use of
this energy
going to enhance my life or is it just
wasted energy am i getting involved in a
political argument with people where i'm
going to use up all my energy and will i
have changed the world no
am i going to use up all my energy to
try to convince other people to change
their life or change their way of living
to make them even healthier and they're
not ready to do that i'd be wasting my
energy
so here's an interesting thought
if i gave you an energy checkbook and
asked you to write a check every time
you had to have a thought you would have
to then ask yourself is is this thought
going to enhance my life or is this
thought going to take away from my life
and then when you start to realize that
you start to direct your actions where
you put your energy into things that
enhance your life and give you an
opportunity to survive and to go beyond
survival and really into thriving
so the point is this we are facing some
rough times the more thoughts you put
into the negative aspect the more
thoughts you put into the fear not only
are you just wasting your energy but as
in the biology belief these negative
thoughts these negative stresses
actually impair your immune system and
bring on disease itself
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number three invest in
yourself with joe dispenza when i'm
going through change in my life or i
have a specific outcome that i want to
create i love to get up early in the
morning that's my time i'm a 4 30 in the
morning guy because
that's my time the rest of the day i'm
serving but
i love getting up early and changing and
working and having some time to myself
and i believe that when i invest in
myself i invest in my future and that
time in my in my morning nobody bothers
me because that's my time
and because of brain waves and brain
chemistry
the door between the conscious mind and
the subconscious mind is more open
and so if i get up early and i'm kind of
between theta and alpha i don't have to
work as hard i'm not thinking i just
kind of relax into the moment
in the evening i always ask myself how
did i do
how was one lifetime in one day where
did i fall from grace what happened
and so
then when i look at seeing how i reacted
to someone or something or i made the
choice that i could have made a better
choice i naturally and we all do this
begin to think well if the same
situation happened again how would i do
it differently
and that's the act of beginning to come
up with a new plan
the act of rehearsing it in your mind
begins to install the circuits in your
brain priming your brain so that when
the next experience happens you could
modify your behavior to do a better job
in life that's called plasticity
so
it doesn't matter for me what meditation
i do any longer i like to just get up in
a new state of being i have people say
to me hey um
i miss my meditation today like i'm
supposed to go like this or something
and i say to them
eyes open our eyes closed
you know my eyes open our eyes closed
you know when you're passionate about
something you know when people can't get
up in the morning and they can't get out
of bed i'm going to tell you why
because they can predict the feeling of
everything that's going to happen in
their life and their bodies resigned to
the familiar it says oh another mundane
day but remember when you were a kid and
you were going on a field trip what
happened then
you were up and dressed and ready to go
before your parents were up you know why
because you knew something unexpected
was going to happen that's how we should
live our lives waking up with the
understanding to expect the unexpected
and something unusual should happen in
our life as a result of our efforts and
it's just those beginning moments where
it begins to happen that we begin to
prove to ourselves how powerful we
really are so take time in the morning
in the evening and the rest of the day
check in with yourself at certain times
to see if you're still in that energy
and if you're not excuse yourself for a
second raise your energy and step back
into your life if you keep doing that
over and over again
you'll become less frustrated less
impatient less judgmental it'll just
become something of the past and you'll
be someone else rule number four grow an
abundance mindset with louise hay so
many people think that money is the most
important thing in the world if they
don't have money they would just die
but that's not true
there's a substance that is far more
precious and far more important to us
that we literally can't live without
what is that
love no plenty of people are miserable
and lonely most of their life and and
and live
air your air your breath your breath is
the most important thing that you have
the most precious thing if you didn't
take another breath you wouldn't last
three minutes and you'd never get out of
this room
and yet we absolutely take for granted
that our next breath is there look at us
we're all in this room breathing and i'm
not saying don't breathe there's not
enough for me
we assume that it's there
and when we exhale we don't think about
where's my next breath coming from
now
if the power that created us
has given us enough breath to last for
as long as we shall live
can we not begin to trust that the other
things will take care of themselves
see life is here for us life is here to
support us to take care of us to be here
for us the entire planet
has been put here for us to play with
we have everything that we shall ever
need it's already here only we have to
know it and we have to trust it and we
have to acknowledge it
do you realize that there is more food
on this planet than people could
possibly eat
there's an incredible amount of food yes
it is true that there are people
starving
but the food is here
there is more money on this planet than
we know how to count
the money is here
now there are lots of people who are
very broke but the money is here
there are billions of people on this
planet
and yet you will have people tell you
that they're lonely
it has nothing to do with not being
people
it's what we're doing with our heads
everything is here for us for every dis
ease on this planet there is a plant
that will cure it
everything everything is here for us
and the more we begin to trust life
and acknowledge the beauty and
magnificence of our own being the more
we find everything we need it just pops
up and rule number five the last one
before some very special bonus clips is
access your inner power with eckhart
tolle there is a source of power in you
that transcends the person and it's not
egoic power over somebody
and it's one with a power that
is the power of life in the universe
where all life
arises and
people sometimes have a problem with
self-confidence
[Music]
or
valuing yourself
and
sometimes
you try to convince yourself but
changing your thinking that
you are actually good enough
that you should be self-confident
but there is a better way
to to find
the source of self-confidence
on the egoic level self-confidence is
there because you see you can tell
yourself
i'm actually more intelligent than most
of these people
or
i'm better looking than most i have to
remind myself that i'm better looking
than most and then okay yeah i feel a
bit more confident now
or you say i actually have more money
than these people so i should i
have more self-confidence
whatever it is some way of convincing
yourself and then you compare yourself
with others
and then you focus in
on those areas where you feel superior
to others and trying not to think about
other areas where inevitably you are
inferior to others because you cannot be
superior in all areas
it's a complicated game when you start
start comparing yourself to other people
and if you want to bolster your
self-confidence and you only have to
focus on where you feel i'm actually
better than most but that doesn't really
work that well
so
there is a better way of self-confidence
that is nothing to do with comparing
yourself with others
or with feeling you are better than or
not as good as
and that is direct access
to inner power
you don't need any comparison
you can
have it right now at this very moment
if you're not stuck in your thinking
mind
but take your attention a little bit
beyond the thinking mind
and then realize
that you are
the presence behind the thinking mind
without which there could be no thinking
you're the aware presence behind it all
that that is deeper you've gone deeper
than the thinking mind
and that aware presence
is
where power
resides
and it's not yours
because it connects you with universal
power
therefore
you don't need to compare yourself to
anybody anymore
or feel as the ego always does
[Music]
that you are either
superior or inferior to somebody else
that's a not a comfortable way to live
where you have to classify yourself when
you meet people
[Laughter]
and so you have the fears always
i might be inferior
or
behind that fear is a desire to be
superior
creating daily success routines is the
secret to getting everything that you
want everything that you want out of
life out of business your hopes your
dreams your ambitions everything that
you want lie on the other side of what
you are doing daily of your daily
success habits and routines i think we
let ourselves down by default i think we
worry about other people's opinions by
default i think we play small every day
by default i think you should have
already accomplished a lot of the things
that are on your list but you're stuck
in procrastination mode because you are
playing small by default because you are
not consistent because you do not have
the habits on a daily basis to keep
going consistency consistency
consistency is the difference maker
chart your start what you do in the
first 15 minutes of your day matters
chart your start have a plan of action
most people wake up like an accident
most people wake up they're tired you
pull out your phone you start looking at
your email and what are you doing when
you're looking at your email or looking
at social media you're responding to
other people's emergencies you wake up
you're tired and the first thing you do
is you start responding to other
people's emergencies i want you to
control the first part of your day chart
your start understand what it is that
makes you come alive understand what is
the action that helps you feel bold
creative unstoppable we've all had it
you've all had moments where you felt
bold courageous and unstoppable what led
to that reverse engineer yourself what
led to you feeling bold is it watching
the video is it reading a book is it
having a conversation is it doing a
meditation is it taking your dog out for
a walk is it cutting the grass like i
don't care there's no judgment i don't
care what the thing is that makes you
feel bold and courageous and unstoppable
i just want you to do it daily i want
you to start your day with intention
most people don't start their day with
intention and that makes the difference
between the people who achieve success
and the ones who don't and so chart your
start figure out the thing that makes
you come alive that makes you feel like
that big crazy idea of yours is actually
possible and put that into the first 15
minutes of every day
if you did the thing that made you feel
bold courageous and unstoppable in the
first 15 minutes of waking up every
single day
not every day will be amazing but i
guarantee you that your life will look
unrecognizable from where you are right
now
chart your start productivity is very
simple it's a measurement to me i
actually am productive 64 hours a day
and the reason that i'm productive 64
hours a day i call it the power of 64 is
that i focus in on having twice as many
productive hours so most people work
eight productive hours i work 16.
i then focus in on the efficiencies of
those hours to turn the 16 hours to
twice as efficient to 32 hours of
production
and then i look at the statistical
success of what i'm doing to double that
to create 64 hours of production
so when people ask me how do you speak
internationally have your own radio show
on cnbc run a business have a family of
four kids happy marriage travel do all
these things well it's easy because i
have 64 hours a day
that i'm doing things
and it may sound silly but i've actually
changed my life by creating and playing
with time let me give you some examples
of what to do i take everything
everything that i do by the minute hour
day month year
and i look at it and i create systems it
may sound a little ocd or lane or
attentive but it actually works so i
took for example i brushed my teeth lost
my teeth and take listerine every
morning
and i took that and i started realizing
that i would days off and forget what
tooth and it took me an average of six
minutes a day
but if i stayed focused in the morning
and that small little thing that i do
every day i could save four minutes
four minutes time seven day was 28
minutes a week times four weeks in a
month was two hours a month times 12
months was 24 hours that i regained the
productivity all because i stayed
focused when i brush my teeth floss my
teeth and take a shot of listerine
other things happen i realize that time
is compressed in the morning
so i'm not sure if you can looking at me
realize it i've spent hours of wasted
time in the closet wondering what to
wear
i sit there in the morning no matter how
late i am like oh
that or i've lost a sock or i can't find
the right belt
and so i learned this little trick that
i had when i was five years old is i lay
out my clothes at night
but the challenge is when i analyzed
that is i didn't want to take away from
the time with my children at night so i
incorporated that with in laying out my
clothes so i took my girls and i let
them lay out my clothes so they learned
colors and sizes
geography where things were bought
finance i did all kinds of type of
things
and now my six-year-old son because i
travel a lot he actually gets excited
when i leave because he gets to lay out
my clothes
and my oldest daughter who's 17 walks by
and tells me oh daddy i miss laying out
your clothes with you
see how this universal energy has
created itself into efficient effective
statistically successful things in my
life that have nothing to do with
business
it's a matter of putting energy and
creating the habits in performance is
there any daily disciplines that you
have in your life daily routines that
you would attribute to your success
uh
yeah i try to beat the sun up
i write my goals down every day
and i try to get i try to hit the gym
so i don't do it perfect every day sure
um some things throw me off and and um
you know unfortunately i have a i
created a lifestyle where where some
things are taking care for me that that
that um
most people don't have that that option
you know somebody drives the kids to
school i don't have to do that that
would change everything
if i had to do that who knows maybe i
need to maybe i need to start driving
the kids to school it seems like a
complete waste of time to me but
um i live two two minutes from my office
so when i bounce out of here i gotta go
do a live a live stream on real estate
but but
uh
yeah that that's the first three things
if i can get that done in the morning
man i know i'm gonna have a good day
yeah pretty simple to beat the sun up
make sure you write down your goals yeah
make sure you take care of yourself get
the blood flow and get the heart pumping
yeah and goes down fresh a new unit like
in a new unit of time like i write them
down today like i had never written them
down before thanks
yeah
that's um so so so simple on the outside
but so many people won't do
those
i dare everybody listening here to try
to do it for 30 days in a row see if you
can even make seven most of you lose
control of your life in the first five
minutes after you wake up i talk about
it in my book and you begin to respond
all day long the first thing is this the
hardest thing you will do and the thing
that will change your life almost with
the greatest impact is to not check your
phone for the first 30 minutes you wake
up in the morning i'm telling you that
it might be the biggest game changer it
is the biggest game changer for me it
was so difficult because so what i did
is i i moved it away from where i sleep
but i'm just going to say to you all you
think that's not a big deal i got to
check it i'm telling you if you could go
30 minutes if you could start by going
10 minutes to begin your day something
where you do not check that sticker and
react and then what you say about the
gratitude thing that's profound for me
and it's a breakthrough for me when you
said it i'm always kind of like what are
the big things i'm great i'm grateful
for god i'm grateful for my kids you
reduce it down to just something what's
the smallest thing you could be grateful
for right i love that because there's
always a small thing you'd be grateful
for you know i'm grateful my i clipped
my toenails yesterday whatever it is
right there's something so i just want
to validate how powerful i think both
those simple tools the simplest things
make the biggest impacts in our life
what's your morning routine
every morning without fail the first
thing i do is i run without fail i
haven't missed a day of running since
2016. okay so i get up i do that four
days out of the week i go to the gym and
every single night
for five and a half years i stretch out
for at least two hours that was a killer
part of the book every [ __ ] night
that is that's where i so when you go so
hard
mentally physically emotionally
spiritually you have to have time set
aside to quiet
and recover
recovery is big the mind especially the
mind and the body
this is my time there's no phone calls
there's no emails the world does not
exist
because i have to get ready for tomorrow
get the body opened up why because as i
i won't get you know two years you went
deeper
it was awesome but your body's getting
tight yeah you go hard tom yeah a lot of
people go hard what happens is that
stress yep starts to tighten up that
psoas muscle hip flexors so lower back
you got back problems all of a sudden
you have no idea why it's all tightness
it's all tightness man because you're
constantly charged and going hard well
look i mean i think that emotions are
energy in motion
and so let's just say that um
we share the same experiences okay i
don't we're friends and we share the
same experience you're from london i've
been to london my daughter lives in
london and we have hey you do this i do
that you did the you know you own this i
own that you know so what we do is we
actually look to see when we meet people
if we're matching neurologically if
we're matching emotionally so if we
share the same experiences we share the
same emotions and if we share the same
emotions we can relate to one another so
this is where it gets sticky so then the
moment you start saying ah
that person did that to you once yeah
that person i had a similar experience
to that person that to me now
now
we open the door like i'm going to use
you to reaffirm
my
attachment to that emotion
and let's just work it up so that you
can suffer and i can suffer and then we
can have a conversation and literally
we're sharing the same energy and if
we're sharing the same energy we're
sharing the same information and we're
bound by an invisible field
of energy that keeps us connected yes so
then what does it take to break that
energetic field and energy that's
greater than the energy that's holding
it together that's how you separate
atoms that become a molecule you they're
they're bound by an invisible field of
energy that's keeping them connected so
you got to use a greater energy than the
energy that's holding them together to
separate them well in order for you to
change then you can't have energy
without awareness or consciousness
you've got to go to a greater level of
consciousness and change your energy and
nobody changes j until they change their
energy and when they change their energy
they change their life so then
you may say well this person you know i
i use this person and i use my enemy to
reaffirm my addiction to hatred i use my
co-worker to reaffirm my addiction to
judgment i use my ex to reaffirm my
addiction to resentment that we have
these different people in our lives that
we need to remind us of who we think we
are the enemy dies and you find another
one
you know you know your co-worker uh
leaves and you start judging another one
it's just
it's not any it's not that so then
when there's no longer a vibrational
match
when you start doing the work
there's no longer a vibrational match
with you and your past present reality
that that person or that condition any
longer
that person or condition is going to
spiral away because you're no longer
you're no longer in need of that so then
our life begins to change when we change
our energy and we begin to take our
power back that's essential for us to
begin to create with now some people
can't handle that because
they're not conscious that they're doing
it so they'll be working on their vision
of the future
and yet they'll spend two hours
lowering their energy back into
victimization or suffering and they want
to know why their future isn't happening
well there's an unconscious program
let's go after that and once you start
going after that
now all of a sudden your life starts to
change again so you can't say it doesn't
work
on some level we don't work and if
you're really invested in this
the question is what is it about me
where am i directing my attention or my
energy who am i using to reaffirm some
conditioning that i need to remember as
my old self so then when you stop
reacting to the person or the person is
now complaining to you and you're not
complaining back
it's going to be an uncomfortable moment
because
you're all of a sudden seeing a part of
you
you used to be that you no longer are
and you have to be willing to not go
there and over time that person will
thank you and they'll say i didn't even
know that i was complaining that much
and
by changing yourself you help others
when things are bad you feel bad so
there's dramatic contrast and polarity
and this is the realm of polarity right
so how do you find the middle path well
the heart is the middle path it's the
union of polarity it's the union of
opposites it's it's oneness it's
wholeness and this is where we have to
begin to create from all of this down
here is all humanity this is all our
animal nature we get up in here things
change right
you go from selfish to selfless and
something else happens so
it's really funny too because when
a lot of people come they say i i don't
know i'm having difficulty opening my
heart
i'm you know i'm practicing but i'm not
feeling anything yet and then it comes
time to do our healings on other people
and
the moment you it was no longer about
you all of a sudden something happened
well of course that's what the heart is
about right so
so it comes in ways that we least expect
at times a habit is a redundant set of
automatic
unconscious thoughts behaviors and
emotions that's acquired through
repetition
a habit is when you've done something so
many times that the body now knows how
to do it better than the mind
so now the person
running through the same routine every
single day is on autopilot and their
body's now dragging them
into a predictable future based on what
they did in the past and they've lost
their free will
to a set of programs right so now you
have the familiar past and you have the
predictable future those are knowns
so the only place then reasonably where
the unknown exists is the sweet spot of
the generous present moment that is when
the body and mind are free from those
conditions so along with those emotions
that influence the same thoughts
people start becoming more judgmental
they start becoming more impatient they
start becoming more entitled they start
getting more afraid more anxious more
depressed and now the body is literally
being depleted
of energy because it's believing that
it's living in an emergency situation
and in emergency you tap all the body's
resources for some threat whether it's
real or imagined
and so then when you're releasing all of
these chemicals we are literally drawing
the body's life force and turning it
into chemistry and so for the short term
that's cool
but the arousal that's created from
those stress hormones
is a rush of energy
and so then people use the problems
and the conditions in their life to
reaffirm their conditioning or their
addiction to that emotion
and in a sense they become addicted to
the life they don't even like
and this is why change is so hard
so then when a person makes up their
mind to change and they say okay i'm not
going to say i can't i'm not going to
judge another person i'm not going to
blame i'm not going to complain i'm not
going to make excuses i'm not going to
be a victim i'm not going to talk trash
about anybody i'm just going to stop
well that works out really well for the
first couple hours
then the body's saying you're out of
schedule you normally at eight in the
morning you're getting traffic and
you're angry then at 11 o'clock you
check your emails and you're really
judgmental and frustrated the body's
saying well you've been doing this for
the last 20 years you're just going to
stop today so now the body which has
been conditioned emotionally to be the
mind wants to return back to its
familiar territory to the known
so the body starts influencing the mind
and it says you know come on
this is a good time to judge that come
on this is a good time to suffer it's
your ex's fault it's it's your it's the
government's fault it's uh
you know it's the weather what the news
whatever it is and if we
accept
believe and surrender to that thought
without analyzing it it slips by and it
begins to program the autonomic nervous
system to make those pharmacy of
chemicals
and so that's when the person makes the
same choice
does the same thing
creates the same experience just for
that familiar feeling
okay i'll complain just so i can feel
suffering then they'd rather
be unhappy
and step in for a moment
do you know that every living soul gets
exactly the same amount of time
exactly the same amount of time
figure it out
you get all there is
a hobo sleeping under a bridge or on a
park bench
that has no material possessions
none
does nothing of any
constructive nature
that person gets exactly the same amount
of time as the most
productive industrialist in the world
we all get exactly the same amount of
time so it's what we do with the time
that makes a difference
i want you to think of the number of
time management programs almost everyone
under the sun has time management
programs
in fact i made one one time spent a lot
of money on it
and then i found out it was a dumb waste
of time and money
do you know why
time can't be managed i was having
breakfast with earl nightingale one
morning
and it was downtown chicago
and i was going with him on his speaking
engagement
and it was early in the morning he said
you want to meet for breakfast
whenever el nino said you want to meet
me i was there and i always had some
well-prepared questions and i remember
asking him i said uh how did you learn
how to master time management you know
we're having breakfast i can still hear
his fork hit the plate he's what the
hell you're talking about
he's i've never mastered time management
nobody masters time management he said
time can't be managed
he's i merely manage activity
and he took a little card out of his
pocket
and he said every night before i go to
bed i write down six most important
things i have to do tomorrow these are
goal achieving activities and when i
wake up that's what i start working on
and if i don't get them all done i'll
add them to tomorrow's list
you should have about six
now if i have three that i didn't get
done today that doesn't mean i have nine
for tomorrow like six plus these three
those three become part of the six you
have to do the next day
when you wake up you give all your
conscious attention to do those things
see you cannot manage time
but you can manage activity
you can manage your activities
make certain that what you're doing
really makes a difference makes certain
that you're spending your time on
activities that are productive that are
taking you in the direction of your goal
there's a process which has made more
people rich than any other single
process of goals achieving
and it's to take your major goal and
structure it as a question if your goal
is to earn 100 000 dollars a year then
you write how can i earn 100 000 dollars
in the next 12 months that's an
open-ended question not how can i earn
it at my job or doing a specific thing
just an open-ended question how can i
earn the amount of money
and then you discipline yourself to
write 20 answers to the question
and the 20 answers are all the different
things that you could think of to earn a
hundred thousand dollars work longer
work harder upgrade my skills
get a new job take a part-time
opportunity
whatever it happens to be write down
everything you could think of but force
yourself to write at least 20 questions
or 20 answers to the question
the 20 question method called
mindstorming forces you to dig deep deep
into your mind where you will find all
your answers and it may be call a person
uh read a book
let me give you an example we had a
young fellow entrepreneur he got 35
years old he built a successful business
he worked about 10 years to do it and he
for two years wanted to sell his
business so he could take a year off and
travel enjoy his money and so for two
years he just sort of floundered around
like a fish on the dock wanting to sell
his business nobody
offered to buy it he suggested it to
people people were not interested and so
on and in this exercise that they put
him through his 20th answer and often
it's the 20th answer that is the
breakthrough was
buy a book on how to sell your own
business
and it just went off like a flash bulb
in his mind at the break he got up as a
downtown hotel got up went down the
street to a major bookstore went and
found he was amazed at the number of
books had been written on how to buy and
sell a business so he bought two or
three books two months later he had
restructured packaged his business sold
it completely satisfactorily and took a
year off
he said but it's just a single idea it
was a breakthrough idea but it was so
simple just get a book on the subject
and you think boy that's pretty obvious
yes but it's the most obvious answers
that we overlook there is a reason many
of the great women and men of the world
the great history makers the great poets
the great philosophers the great
movement makers rose before the sun
there is a magic in the air at 5 a.m and
that's why the 5am club is so
transformational because it's the time
of greatest quietude and i believe
tranquility is the new luxury on our
planet it is a time of intimate
creativity because you've just been
rested your brain is fresh there's
there's latest
there's there's very recent cutting-edge
science coming out now when you sleep
your brain actually has a mechanism to
wash itself when you wake up in the
morning your willpower is strongest when
you wake up in the morning you've got a
full well of mental focus and we know
that focus in our world is even more
valuable than intelligence and i could
go on and on on the benefits i mean you
get up at 5 a.m you've got the world to
yourself there's no crowds you can think
you can plan you can care for yourself
in a world where so many people are so
depleted and so the fi it the 5 a.m club
really is a game changer and then it's
not just get up at 5am and you know
scratch your stomach or stare up at the
ceiling or look at your phone or look at
especially not i believe you can play
with your phone or change the world you
don't get to do both yeah and so uh it
the 5am club method is based on the 20
20 20 formula i'm happy to get into it
but that is yeah tell us what it is
that's the revolutionizer and and it
started from my experience with working
with many billionaires i've i've coached
many of the most successful financiers
and titans of industry for for over two
decades
and one of the things i would run them
through is the way you begin your day
sets up the way you live your day and so
the 20 20 20 formula that the book is
based upon is pretty simple i i go into
great detail in the book but
essentially it's from five to five
twenty the first pocket is move
and i'm a fanatic about neuroscience and
why do you get up and move because
you're gonna release serotonin which is
going to make you feel better you're
going to release dopamine which is the
pleasure and inspirational
neurotransmitter you're going to release
norepinephrine which will boost your
focus you'll promote neurogenesis marie
you can actually grow new brain cells
you'll increase your metabolic rate so
the way you beg the way you feel when
you first wake up is not the way you're
going to feel at 5 20. second pocket of
the 20 20 20 formula 20 minutes from 5
20 to 5 40 that's on reflection so a lot
of us are busy but what's the point of
being busy if you're doing the wrong
things
the the billionaires the great creatives
the people of great impact the people
who live beautiful lives are very
intentional they're very deliberate
they're very conscious so for 20 minutes
you write in a journal
you can visualize you can pray you can
meditate you can simply
contemplate
how you're going to live your day what
you want to stand for during the day for
example and then the final pocket of the
20 20 20 formula is all about grow and
that's where you you you just read from
a biography or a business book or a
philosophy book or a time watch a
marietv well especially watching tv yeah
of course that's the game changer isn't
it and so that's 20 minutes of growing
because i think we're most alive when we
are growing yes and um i believe the
leader who learns the most wins if i
immediately when i wake up i can't check
my phone in fact i put it on airplane
mode and i move it i got that from
ariana huffington who's amazing and
she's like is your phone still by your
bed she goes airplane mode on the other
side of the room you know
um
so that and then
i just know so many people roll over and
grab their phone and to me that's like
russian roulette you put a bullet in the
gun and you spin it it's like what if
the email says the deal didn't happen
numbers are down life's not working out
like
and immediately for me it's like you
open up and and this little box is gonna
dictate the first couple hours or maybe
the whole day by what you see so i just
i just won't look at my phone when i
first wake up
um so but when i first opened my eyes
this is all and i like doing things
quick for me because i want to get to
the gym because the only time of day
i'll go if i try to wait till the
afternoon it doesn't work for me so as
soon as i wake up i immediately try to
think of something i'm grateful for
which everybody knows that and thinks
about but i've i play this game myself
on how far i can lower the bar
meaning
i i try to do a gratitude journal about
three years ago and after about five
weeks i ran out of stuff to say i'm like
i already wrote my kids and this and
life like what did i put in here like
and then i was like wow 150 000 people
die every single day you can google it
that's the number it's like some days i
wake up i'm just like i'm here awesome
and i let i feel that silly little thing
like i'm here or i'll be like oh my god
the sheets feel
softer than they've ever felt and i'll
literally think to myself these sheets
are really good like what a third of the
world sleeps on the on a dirt floor
and i have sheets in an amazing bed and
look at the view i have and that's
enough just because the way i know is
i'm just just tweaking my brain enough
to be in a grateful place it doesn't
have to be this for me and you guys
might have better practices i'm not
talking about a half hour gratitude
meditation i just need one little thing
or i pick up a book if i'm reading one
of the books that you have on the shelf
i'll pick and i'll just pick three
sentences and read something empowering
and i'll get that state of mind for my
brain and then i think about
one win i had the day before because i
know as entrepreneurs as somebody
searching for success we never give
ourselves credit we never treat a friend
the way we treat ourselves it's like i
know i've had days i've gone till 10
o'clock at night go man i got nothing
done today was the biggest lie like we
beat ourselves up we just were like
these racehorses we wouldn't even treat
a racehorse that we owned as bad as we
treat ourselves right so
i wake up and i'll do a quick little
gratitude and i'll say what was one win
yesterday that i accomplished and i'm
like wow you did do that yesterday and
then i'll think of one win i want to do
that day like what i'm gonna need a
million things done today but what's a
must today that would be a great win
and then for me then i immediately go
downstairs in my house and i drink i
felt like i fed my my mind and then i
want to feed my body so for me i've been
doing the same drink forever i do apple
cider vinegar lemon mct oil a scoop of
green powder
and uh mix that up and i down that and
then i immediately gotta go to the gym
if you put your shoe on your shoe is
untied
that's a problem that you need to figure
out right and so
at some point the first time maybe that
requires some effort but once you tie
your shoes 100 or 500 times you can
pretty much automate that solution and
do it on autopilot
the same is true for pretty much every
area of life right like if you come home
from work and you're stressed and
exhausted that's a problem that you need
to figure out but there are a variety of
solutions that could solve it you could
play video games for an hour you could
smoke a cigarette you could go for a run
for 20 minutes you could meditate for 10
minutes and any of those solutions uh
whatever one that you come into your
brain starts to fall into that like the
mom who's going to mcdonald's where
she's like i have a problem i need to
feed my kids it's 5 30.
and mcdonald's is now a solution and
you're like hey this was easy i should
just automate the solution as much as i
can
and so the key is to try to find a
solution that
delivers the same outcome that solves
the same problem but is also about as
convenient as the previous one otherwise
it's really hard because then you're
just you're trying to opt for a less
convenient solution and the brain
doesn't want to do that it wants to
automate and conserve energy not spend
more energy
that makes a ton of sense you know to
your
second
solution being able to sit with it i
think that's what is so critical
and you hear about this in books like
the obstacle is the way in other books
similar that nature where
when you're able to face certain
challenges consistently
and sit with those challenges like an
ice bath or an extended water fast in
those experiences they can be
extrapolated out to all experiences yes
right so like if i can go without food
which is one of the most
primal messages my brain will tell my
body like oh i'm hungry especially
because it's around us 24 7 right and
we're inundated with ads and smells and
all these things
but if i can figure out a way to carve
out a four-day block of water only
that gives me strength going into all
sorts of other things that are going to
come up for me intermittent fasting is
funny that way i've been doing it for
like let's see how uh seven or eight
years now and um
there are a lot of solutions that sound
really easy at first but then are
actually hard to implement you know uh
it's like just do do p90x do insanity
and you'll get fit and people like oh
yeah all right i get really motivated
and then it's like they fall off course
after like two weeks or whatever
intermittent fasting is like the
opposite it's hard for people to wrap
their head around it at first like what
do you mean i don't eat breakfast it's
like very difficult for them to get over
that uh because we've been conditioned
that way but then it's actually really
easy to do like you just you don't do
anything you just don't eat you just go
to work like just get started there's
nothing there's no action to take um so
i don't know i need like a phrase for
for things like that but it is nice that
um what i've noticed is such a small
benefit that has nothing to do with
fasting itself is that it does translate
to other areas you know it's like no i
don't need the meal like i was flying
yesterday and it's like well i don't
need to eat any of the crap food that's
in the airport you know like yeah oh
they only got [ __ ] peanuts it's fine
i'll be it's gonna be six hours i'll be
fine you know like it's not a big deal
you're not gonna die yeah i remember
thinking the same thing i played
baseball all the way through college and
you know like many sports we had this
kind of like hell week in the beginning
we're you know training conditioning and
everything before the season starts
and um
i remember doing that in the morning we
it started at like 6 a.m and then you
know we got done and i was in class at
like you know nine or something and we
had a test and everybody was freaking
out many of us have issues with
productivity
maybe we are overly productive but we're
feeling burned out all the time or we're
not productive at all because we don't
know where to start
i found personally being in business for
myself for the last 20 years that i have
been a little overly productive i almost
did too much and i was constantly
multitasking and making things happen
and just moving so fast that ultimately
i really burnt out and i started feeling
brain fog i was feeling disoriented i
couldn't focus i was feeling like even
though i for so many years was priding
myself on the fact that i could get so
much done at one time i actually don't
think i was being nearly as productive
as i could have been so i hit a bottom
recently with this productivity overload
and i realized that i had to change my
patterns i had to change my ways i was
then blessed i said a prayer i said i
need some help with my brain fog and i
need some help with my productivity
issue and i that day got an email from
the dr oz show asking me to come on and
do a segment with this lovely author and
dr dr mike dao and me and mike had been
in touch many years um for many years
just because he hadn't been an author we
were published by the same publishers
and mike had written a book about brain
fog so that day i'm like thank you
universe you're giving me exactly what i
need i go on dr oz with mike and i'm
backstage with him and i'm like listen
i'm feeling so
chaotic and i'm multitasking so much and
my i feel like i've got brain fog and
i'm forgetting things and he looked to
me says how much are you doing at one
time and i said oh mike i'm doing a
million things at once i have a thousand
tabs up on my screen and he's like these
are big brain no-no's and they're also
productivity no-no's is what he said
because he said that the more i try to
do and the more i try to multi-task the
less i'm actually getting done so he
gave me a tip that i want to share with
you that has changed everything for me
and his suggestion was to just do five
things a day
to make a list of the five most
important things that i need to do that
day and not do number two until i've
completed number one
and then once i complete number one move
on to number two then on to number three
and if i don't get through all five in
one day i'll just pick up the fifth the
next day or wherever i left off i'll
pick up the next day
and to really stick to that list and not
move back and forth and not try to make
a million other things added onto that
list and just be really committed to
that five task list
i did it i started to just be very clear
about the five things i was doing in a
day i told my team i made a a list in my
base camp which is where we keep all of
our notes and i made it really clear to
myself these are the only five things
i'm doing throughout the day
as a result of making it super clear and
conscious to myself that i was only
going to do five things i have been more
productive i have created more have been
more intuitive i have been more inspired
and i've been more creative i want to
talk a little bit about goals on the
line of how do you lose 37 pounds and
write a book i'm just going to kind of
give you that as an example for 24 years
of my adult life by choice i weighed
well over 200 pounds
i say by choice because you see i have
never accidentally eaten anything
i mean it's always been deliberate
and when i choose to eat too much today
i have chosen to weigh
too much tomorrow
you can choose to set goals
and realize your potential
or you can choose not to set them now if
you choose not to set them you got to
understand that the consequences are not
going to be good
down the road for 24 years i was going
to lose that weight as a matter of fact
in 24 years i lost several thousand
pounds of weight how many of you already
know exactly what i'm talking about but
it wasn't until i wrote it down
put a date on it
listed the obstacles i had to overcome
identified the people the groups
organizations i needed to work with
spelled out a plan of action set that
time limit in there and identified all
of the benefits to me it was only when i
did that that the goal became a reality
and i lost the weight for 10 or 15 years
i was going to write a book you know
anybody who's going to do just a whole
lot of things folks i was going to write
a book but it wasn't until i got busy
writing the book and writing the plans
first before the book ever materialized
now if it sounds like i'm trying to sell
you on heaven goals how many of you are
getting close already how many of you
are becoming convinced right quick like
that you need to have those goals
there's no question about it the
immortal j.c penney many many years ago
said give me a stock clerk with a goal
and i'll give you a man who will make
history but give me a man
without a goal
and i'll give you
a stock clerk
now the interesting thing is golds do
not care who has them let me give you a
classic example of the way they work in
1950 a war-torn devastated japan
a nation which had lost an incredibly
high percentage of its young men their
cities were in ruins they had been
bombed out but in 1950 they got together
they meaning industry and government got
together and set a goal the goal was
we're going to be the number one nation
in the world during the 1950s in the
production of textiles
in
1959 ladies and gentlemen they
accomplished that objective in 1960 they
set another goal we're going to be the
number one nation in the world in the
production of steel now when you
understand there's no iron ore in japan
of any significance there's no coal of
any significance there we're going to be
the number one nation in the world in
the production of steel it seemed like
an absurd goal and yet they reached
their objectives they had taken all of
the steps in 1970 the japanese set
another goal they said during the 70s
we'll be the number one nation in the
world in the production of automobiles
they missed it folks
one year it took them until 1980. in
1980 they set another goal and this time
their goal was we're going to be the
number one nation in the world in the
production of computers and electronics
yes indeed ladies and gentlemen you
absolutely must have those goals you got
to write them down you got to put a date
on it you got to identify those
obstacles you've got to identify the
people the groups you need to work with
you got to find out what it is you need
to know you got to develop a plan of
action and you got to write it down
what's in it for me
now that's a formula that i have just
given you pure and simple so when i wake
up in the morning
the first thing i do is i do a gratitude
exercise where i ask myself usually in
bed what am i most grateful for today
and usually you know i'm grateful for my
health i'm grateful for my wife i'm
grateful for my children i'm grateful to
be alive i'm grateful you know for my
family i'm grateful to to have
experiences and do you do that eyes
closed yeah i do that eyes closed and
while i
while i think about that i feel it
and so the feeling starts every day with
a great feeling
i start every day with a great feeling
you have do you visualize some things
like your children or do you talk to
yourself how do you do that yeah i have
an internal dialogue
i see images of the things that i'm
thinking about and that just takes me
two minutes just two minutes when i wake
up
and then i go to exercise to take care
of my body how do i um usually one hour
to an hour and 15 minutes every day
and so i do
a variety of different things i hike i
bike i work on aerobics i work on
strength i work with weights i do
whatever it is i just do it to give my
body the physical exercise
then as soon as i finish my exercise
in my gym
around
half an hour an hour 15 minutes at the
moment
so then in my gym i have uh two things i
have a vision board which is my dream
board for my you know you are known for
that yes so i have my vision board for
my my physique and my body and my health
but then i also have in in my gym
something called an achieved board
okay so after i achieved some of the
things that i achieved best in the
future no achieved in the past yes so
past you have the past and the future
so
i have in my in my gym in my home gym i
have a
like a place where i sit and before i
start my meditation
i look at my vision board from the past
okay so i get connected to the different
things that i've been able to achieve
and i remember every day
when i set my mind and my focus
to achieving goals
i can achieve all of my goals but what i
also do is i reinforce most people focus
on what's not working this isn't going
well this didn't work i want to remind
myself every day
of look how many things i was able to
accomplish
by being clear by being passionate by
using these rituals so before i go into
my meditation which is with my eyes
closed
i look at my achieved board i get
emotionally associated with it to remind
myself that when i set my mind to
achieve something
i can do it
and then i look across because i have a
mirror
in the gym and i look across and i say i
love you just the way you are and i said
i accept you just the way you are with
all of your skills and passion and
faults and insecurities and doubts and
fears i accept you just the way you are
and i smile
and then i close my eyes
and i do about a 15-minute meditation
and
in my meditation sometimes i have
no thoughts where i'm just one with the
universe and everything
other times i'll just follow my thoughts
and i'll just pay attention be mindful
of where are they going this morning
where are they going today
so i'll follow my thoughts and i'll just
follow them
other times i'll follow a thought and
say release that one and follow another
thought and say release that one so i'm
teaching my brain
that i'm in control of my brain what
i've said before is that regularity is
critical going to bed at the same time
waking up at the same time and certainly
using alarms can help you do that and i
use the word plural there alarms what i
mean is not to have multiple awakenings
in the morning i mean we should all set
a to bed alarm you know think about the
time that you need to go to bed to get
that eight hour sleep opportunity and
then set the alarm maybe sort of 15
minutes before and that's just the call
it's sort of like last orders at a bar
now is the time to sort of start
preparing to get ready for this sleep
event
you can also by the way just sort of
before sleep in the last hour you can
sort of get into your pajamas your
sleeping clothes brush your teeth flush
your teeth do all of those things that
end up taking away and sort of an
additional 15 minutes or 20 minutes get
those in ahead of time
but what about the snooze button though
unfortunately it's probably not a good
idea because there is some data that i
discuss in the book where if you look at
the cardiovascular response to an alarm
it's actually quite a stressful event
for your cardiovascular system we see a
spike in heart rate stress chemicals
increase
now it's fine to use an alarm just that
one time in the morning to wake you up
but you shouldn't really be hitting the
snooze button because then you are
repeatedly assaulting your
cardiovascular system and you may think
well you know i only hit it maybe sort
of three or four times you know how bad
is that well maybe for that one day it's
not bad but if you're doing that every
single day
every week every month every year every
decade across a lifetime you can imagine
the type of additional cardiovascular
strain that that places on people so use
the alarm that's fine but try to use it
once and then get up
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want the seven powerful morning routines
to destroy your laziness check the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there you've got to remember your
brain needs a certain amount of sleep
and if you don't get that amount of
sleep you can actually test the
cognitive decline so
step number one is really treating sleep